a lot of marketers and sales people like  to talk about the internal thoughts that  someone's had like first they need  awareness and then they need blah blah  and then they and so they're basically  just make up they reverse engineer  fictitious steps of someone's mental  thought process when they have no  evidence to support what someone's  thinking at all  and so i don't find it useful because  it's not useful like what are the things  that are useful these are the things  that are observable that we can drive  action towards that that we create an  outcome and then we have a feedback loop  and so if we have those things then we  can move the variables and get closer to  where we're trying to go and the  feelings although i recognize that they  exist it's just they're not helpful in  trying to edit what our activities are